[Music]
welcome to noob gaming Network so
division tech is making a return in the
state of the game last week they told us
about how a new recalibration station in
1.8 that would help us further optimize
our favorite gear they didn't tell us a
huge amount about it but basically if
you have a favorite pair of gloves for
example but the armor role is a bit low
you can pop it into the recalibration
station to increase the steps further
towards the max role and what currency
does the station use division tick this
is going to be massive for getting the
absolute best out of your builds so this
is just a quick video to show one of the
more efficient ways of getting division
tick this video is more suited to the
new or casual player or those of you
returning to the game after a break
myself I returned to the game a couple
of months ago and I haven't had to farm
for this stuff since 1.1 or 1.2 a long
time ago so I pulled out an old map I
used and update it the best I could for
the duck sir and how it currently is
right now I've only run up to DZ 6
because I haven't really explored enough
of the area above to do it justice it's
probably worth noting that there are
plenty more division tick in the dark
zone that what I'm gonna show you here
this is more of a straight run from
point to point that can be done in about
15 minutes
collecting you a total of 36 division
tick give or take there are other ways
of giving division tick but none this
quick and easy this can be run in a
group or solo it doesn't really matter
the amount of division tick that you can
hold it's mean increase to 4,000 so hit
the ground running when one-point-eight
lands and start stockpiling now I'll
show you a spit up version of the run
now but I've included a map at the end
of this video and if you'd like to skip
to that I've included a link in the
description below I make a couple of
wrong turns I miss a chest towards the
end it should give you the idea also
you'll notice that I picked a horrible
build to do this wood so if you want to
run through it a bit easier not have to
worry about the NPC's use something a
bit tanky air with a bit more
survivability I realize this video isn't
particularly useful for the more
seasoned players out there but I've been
getting asked the question a lot plus
there's a number of us that haven't
really had to farm for it and so long
that we need
refresher course otherwise if you found
this useful please leave the like and
I'll see you in the next video thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]